y
[Música]
en su primera conferencia de prensa con
el equipo lionel messi aseguró soñar con
ganar una nueva champions league de la
mano del paris saint german el astro
argentino dijo sentirse feliz de estar
en la capital francesa y haber elegido
al psc por su mentalidad ganar
en colombia la justicia especial para la
paz se investigará a la ex guerrilla de
las farc por reclutar a 18 mil
667 menores en el país durante el
conflicto armado entre los crímenes
cometidos se encuentra la desaparición
forzada homicidio y violencia sexual
como abortos forzados y acceso carnal
violento
el presidente manuel macro calificó de
dramática la situación que atraviesan
martinica y guadalupe e hizo un llamado
a la solidaridad nacional los
territorios franceses de ultramar
enfrentan confinamientos ante las altas
tasas de contagios por el 19 y los
índices de vacunación siguen siendo muy
bajos
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros aquí en france24 blanco como
siempre un gusto acompañarlos y
comenzamos con la presentación oficial
de lionel messi en el paris saint german
luego de su salida del fc barcelona los
fanáticos del ps ya estallaron de
emoción a las afueras del estadio parque
de los príncipes en parís cuando era
astro argentino salió a saludarlos
previamente en rueda de prensa messi
aseguró que se ha sentido muy feliz a su
llegada a la capital francesa y
agradeció el fichaje por parte del
equipo el argentino de 34 años se mostró
contento de compartir vestuario con los
que catalogó los mejores del mundo en
alusión a sus nuevos compañeros neymar y
kilian en papel entre otros dijo también
soñar con ganar otra champions league y
me acompaña en el estudio de nuestro
periodista deportivo 'juan pupiales
juana muy buen día bienvenido le
pregunto cuál es la primera lectura que
se hace esta presentación de lionel
messi con su nuevo equipo raúl lo
primero que notamos es que hay una
especie de cambio de mentalidad la
última imagen que teníamos de messi fue
esa que vimos en la rueda de prensa de
despedida con el barcelona completamente
roto desde hand o al club que lo formó
en el que se formó como futbolista
aquí nos damos y vemos a un messi que ya
sonríe lo primero que dijo él en esa
rueda de prensa es estoy muy feliz de
haber llegado acá lo segundo que dijo es
estoy aquí para volver a ganar otra
champions él viene de vivir una
pesadilla completamente en la liga de
campeones la última que ganó fue en 2015
a partir de ahí vimos esa remontada
contra el liverpool ese 8 a 2 contra el
bayern él está muy centrado en volver a
levantar el trofeo que todos los
jugadores más anhelan esa liga de
campeones dice que está en el lugar
ideal para hacerlo va a tener a sergio
ramos- va a tener awilda wijnaldum va a
tener al donnarumma h raf el lateral
sensación de europa un verdadero equipo
para hacerlo y lo primero que destacamos
es ya verlo sonreír de nuevo equipazo y
como dices tú parece que la tristeza le
duró solo un par de días pero ahora voy
con la pregunta del millón cuando será
el debut de lionel messi con el pci mes
y viene de jugar la copa américa y salir
campeón con argentina dice que él tiene
que hacer una pretemporada él solo para
recuperarse y ponerse a tono no quiso
dar ninguna fecha en concreto había una
especie de espectativa porque el pce yo
juega este sábado en parís contra el
estrasburgo por la ley and a ese estadio
después de 18 meses para ese partido va
a volver a haber un lleno total de
aficionados hay una especie de
expectativas sobre si ese sería su debut
el no se quiso poner fechas dice que
tiene que volver a recuperar el tono
porque viene de vacaciones así en juan y
hay mucha polémica en torno a si el psoe
ya está rompiendo con el denominado fair
play financiero le pregunto que dijo su
presidente presidente del equipo así
desde el presidente de nacer al khelaifi
el qatarí dijo que antes de cualquier
contratación lo primero que hace el club
es mirar si van a romper o no con el
fair play financiero dice que con el
caso de messi no se está rompiendo
ninguna norma le dijo a la prensa que se
centre en las cosas positivas acerca de
este fichaje para poner esto en contexto
del fair play financiero son las normas
de la uefa que establecen que un equipo
no puede invertir más del 70 por ciento
de sus ingresos en la masa salarial del
equipo ni que tampoco pueden excederse
en el gasto de fichajes ese fue
precisamente el problema que sacó o que
hizo que el barcelona sacar a lionel
messi del barcelona porque el barcelona
tiene una deuda que supera el más del
100 por ciento en sus salarios dice el
veces jay que con el caso de messi que
se estima que ganará unos 45 millones de
euros brutos no se rompe esa norma y que
está todo en regla para poder ver al
messi con neymar y con mbappe en el
tridente ofensivo de ensueño lo que
sobra en ese equipo por supuesto es del
dinero juan muchísimas gracias por todo
el análisis desde este fichaje de messi
en el psc ya nosotros continuamos con
más información venimos a colombia y la
jurisdicción especial para la paz dijo
que 18 mil 667 niños fueron obligados a
unirse a la guerrilla de las farc en un
periodo de 20 años en la investigación
se convocará a 26 ex guerrilleros para
que declaren sobre estas prácticas la
gente para listo 31 bases de datos y el
testimonio de 274 personas también
investigará la violencia de género y
sexual para analizar este tema quiero
saludar en este momento a camilo
gonzález posso él es presidente del
instituto de estudios para el desarrollo
y la paz indepaz señora gonzález posso
gracias por estar aquí con nosotros en
france 24 los hallazgos de este reporte
de lage contradicen directamente las
declaraciones pasadas de los líderes de
las farc que negaban que el grupo
reclutar a menores la jefa ahora habla
de una política sistemática y expresa y
formal de reclutamiento cuál es su
opinión al respecto
pero sobre esto pedía una discusión y
una denuncia en colombia desde hace
muchísimos años es la fiscalía le
entregó a la red una lista de 8.000
casos y el centro nacional de memoria
histórica documentó más de 24.000 casos
en colombia se estableció desde el año
97 cuando hicimos el llamado mandato por
la paz que era completamente prohibido
para el estado y por supuesto para
cualquiera el reclutamiento de menores
de 18 años en esta lista de 18 mil el 68
por ciento incluso son menores de 15
años según lo que ha dicho la gente yo
creo que es muy importante en
investigaciones está demostrando
seriedad avance en los procedimientos de
justicia transicional y al mismo tiempo
están compareciendo los ex combatientes
de las farc a hacer honor a la verdad yo
creo que eso es un gran mensaje para la
sociedad y también para quienes se
mantienen en armas tanto paramilitares
como insurgentes como disidentes y demás
para que tengan en cuenta de qué
humanidad no tolera esto el protocolo
facultativo ha probado
internacionalmente clasificado por
colombia en 2005 estableció toda
prohibición en condiciones interno desde
tratamiento de menores de 18 años usted
tocaba un tema muy importante y es que
le pregunto la importancia que tiene el
informe de esta fricción especial para
la paz en los objetivos de búsqueda de
la verdad y también reparación para las
víctimas en colombia
la verdad que es impresionante el dolor
de la familia buscando a sus familiares
yo presencié cuando se estaba haciendo
el congreso del alfar acogiendo los
acuerdos de paz presencia de familiares
haciendo fila buscando a sus hijos a sus
hijas que de niños habían sido
incorporados a las guerrillas por
diferente manera de manera forzada o
porque se habían alistado y algunos de
ellos desaparecidos la unidad de
búsqueda de personas desaparecidas ya
tiene un listado provisional de varios
centenares de menores de 18 años es un
dolor para colombia es un punto aclarar
pero sobre todo es un asunto de no
repetición la verdad y la no repetición
son fundamentales y no solamente para
esclarecer el pasado y darle
satisfacción a las víctimas sino para
que se supere una situación de violencia
atroz contra las familias campesinas en
su gran mayoría en colombia usted
también hablaba de un tema de violencia
sexual desaparición forzada homicidios
tortura esto corresponde a crímenes
internacionales y además cuáles van a
ser las consecuencias para la gente que
estos actos y la edición especial para
la paz tiene unos unos unas condiciones
precisamente por eso es una justicia
restaurativa
que le da una importancia mayor a la
verdad y en consideración al
esclarecimiento el proceso judicial
que lleve a la verdad se tienen
beneficios
penales disminución de penas hay unos
topes que hacen diferencia con la
justicia ordinaria pero yo creo que más
importante que todo este procedimiento
punitivo o judicial lo más importante es
la sanación para la sociedad es la
reparación a las víctimas y un mensaje
de que esto no puede volver a ocurrir en
la sociedad colombiana señor gonzález
gracias por su tiempo y por estar aquí
con nosotros en frase tipo de analizar
este complejo y el groso panorama en
colombia nosotros continuamos con más
información en el estudio los talibanes
capturaron faisalabad en la provincia
norteña de badakshan la novena capital
regional en caen en manos del grupo
insurgente en menos de una semana el
grupo ya controla dos tercios de
territorio del país a medida que ésta
unidos y la otan completa en el retiro
de su personal militar el talibán logró
además tomarse una base armada en la
estratégica ciudad de kunduz desde la
casa blanca yo vaya me aseguró no
lamentar su decisión de retiro total de
las tropas para finales del mes de
agosto
el presidente francés emmanuel de macrón
aseguró este miércoles que los
territorios franceses de ultramar es de
martinica y guadalupe díaz en una
situación que calificó de dramática
consecuencia de la epidemia de kobe 19
el mandatario es un llamado a la
solidaridad de la nación con estos
territorios y el retiro de iu reiteró la
importancia de la vacunación y es que
martín ica y el territorio francés de
ultramar han entrado a un estricto
confinamiento por el aumento drástico de
los casos de kobe 19 así como las
hospitalizaciones y las muertes
relacionadas con la enfermedad veamos el
informe
las calles de fútbol de ciertas una vez
más las autoridades de martinica han
impuesto tres semanas de confinamiento
estricto y se ha pedido a los turistas
que se vayan de la isla caribeña
los residentes sólo podrán salir cuando
sea absolutamente necesario y a menos de
un kilómetro de sus casas como está
muriendo demasiada gente son nuestras
familias las que están en peligro y
tenemos que hacer algo por martinica
las playas lugares de ocio y tiendas
excepto las de alimentos y medicinas
deberán permanecer cerradas un golpe
para los comerciantes en una época del
año especialmente importante la notebook
y 7 cats era catastrófico especialmente
para quienes dependen de las compras de
retorno a clases aunque reclamar a los
minoristas de una amplia gama de
productos desde europa a material de
papelería y uniformes escolares será
terrible sencillo y nunca tras el
endurecimiento de las medidas se produce
en medio de un empeoramiento de la
situación sanitaria en la isla los
pacientes que están enfermos se ocupan
todas las camas de los hospitales en
este momento son los que contrajeron el
virus hace una o dos semanas todas y no
se es entonces el número de nuevos casos
ha aumentado lo que significa que en las
próximas semanas habrá más
hospitalizaciones el brote empeorará si
no se actúa ahora
en el vecino territorio de walt blue la
situación sanitaria también es
preocupante con casi 1.800 casos por
cada 100.000 habitantes 240 trabajadores
sanitarios de la francia continental
fueron enviados a las dos islas para
ayudar a hacer frente al aumento de los
contagios
y seguimos hablando de la pandemia de
kobe de 19 la preocupación internacional
por el aumento de contagios debido a la
variante delta en eeuu crece una nueva
ola de contagios especialmente en los
estados del sur del país donde las tasas
de vacunación siguen siendo muy bajas en
florida entidad que registra el mayor
número de contagios de hospitalizaciones
los trabajadores de la salud estiman que
el incremento de contagio se ubica por
el orden del 600 por ciento en las
últimas semanas y la mayoría están
asociadas a como ya lo dije la variante
delta adicionalmente en una americana
crece la preocupación por el aumento de
infecciones en niños menores a 12 años
veamos más en el informe que ha
preparado luis méndez
en eeuu el kobe 19 no da tregua expertos
atribuyen el aumento en los contagios a
la animadversión a la vacunación de
algunos ciudadanos el incremento en el
número de contagio está atribuido
principalmente a la variante de alta
entiendo que hay personas decididas
adultos que decidieron no va a pararse
para usted
pero también entiendo que la razón por
la que los niños se infectan es porque
la mayoría de ellos viven en estados y
comunidades donde las tasas de
vacunación son bajas y se infectan por
adultos no vacunados eso es lo que está
sucediendo
a sociable según el 'new york times' de
las personas vacunadas sólo han llegado
al hospital un máximo del 5 por ciento
por otro lado sólo el 6% ha fallecido
o no
hemos abierto más de 5 unidades que
están dedicadas a los pacientes con kobe
19 esto ha sido un gran cambio puesto
que antes atendíamos a 20 o 30 y hoy hay
más de 189
la sangre de ingerir
el último conteo independiente de la
universidad johns hopkins señala que la
unión americana se mantiene como la
nación más afectada con más de 36
millones de contagios y 168.000 86
muertes asociadas a la enfermedad
cambiamos de nuevo de información y nos
vamos al sur del continente americano el
pleno de la cámara de diputados de
brasil rechazó la propuesta liderada por
el presidente yair bolsonaro para
cambiar el sistema de voto electrónico
con 229 votos a favor y 218 en contra y
una abstención- los mentados rechazaron
así incluir una enmienda en la
constitución para adoptar un sistema
mixto de votación en las elecciones con
urnas electrónicas y también papeletas
como exigía el mandatario el sistema
electrónico de votación funciona en
brasil- desde el año
1996 y no ha sido objeto de sospechas de
fraude como alega jair bolsonaro y por
eso quería cambiar entonces la
constitución para hacer este tipo de
voto mixto
y de esta manera llegamos al final de la
informativa en france 24 continua con
nosotros para más actualizaciones de
noticias muy buen día para todos
[Música]